dans le reste de l'actualité ressortez
vos stocks de bougies à l'heure où les
factures de gaz et d'électricité triple
et bien plusieurs grandes villes et
petites communes vont réduire la voilure
par souci d'économie cette année les
illuminations de Noël ne seront pas à la
fête quitte à perdre un peu l'esprit
magique reportage à Château-Renault
romain Delville
faut-il des illuminations pour passer un
bon Noël à Château-Renault telle est la
question posée par la mairie en ces
temps d'économie d'énergie et si oui
quelle période privilégiée quel quartier
et combien de temps en soirée dans la
rue les avis sont tranchés sur
l'opportunité d'éclairer la ville de
manière festive en fin d'année est-ce
que Noël est synonyme d'illumination oui
c'est triste quand il y a pas de
il y a pas de d'illuminations de Noël
sont la plupart du temps hormis les
grandes orgues qu'on a dans les grandes
villes avec des moyens colossaux sont à
chier c'est cheap c'est comme si on
allumait une lampe de chevet j'ai pas
besoin qu'on illumine ça coûte du fric
ça met à côté de ça c'est joyeux mais je
ferais mieux à la mairie de venir tout
chanter des chansons des comptines de
Noël déguisés en pourquoi pas ça ce
serait un peu plus c'est cool ça écolo
ça montrerait leur talents moi je pense
qu'il faut peut-être en garder un petit
peu quand même tout en réduisant
mettre des horaires précis que ce soit
pas nécessaire toute la nuit chaque
année les décorations les illuminations
pendant la période de Noël coûte
habituellement 20.000 euros à la
municipalité sur un budget annuel de 7
millions
mais avec la crise sanitaire passée
maintenant l'inflation galopante les
prix de l'énergie qui augmentent les
budgets des foyers comme ceux des
collectivités sont contraints partagez
entre les festivités et la sobriété la
ville de Château-Renault a donc fait le
choix de la consultation sur ce sujet
des fêtes de fin d'année on rentre dans
une période très difficile on ne sait
pas comment on va faire notre budget
pour 2023 donc on prévoit même de faire
peut-être une année blanche parce qu'on
ne sait pas financièrement où l'on va je
n'ai pas de baguette magique je sais que
les demandes de son de plus en plus
grandissantes qu'elles arrivent qu'on se
doit aussi d'être présent et de répondre
bien sûr aux attentes face aux
incertitudes le choix des festivités de
Noël dans leur durée dans leur nature
est entre les mains des ronaudins la
mairie à d'ores et déjà prévu de
maintenir le feu d'artifice et le
spectacle de fin d'année